[Musique]
alain lui bonjour président de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
cela fait maintenant un peu plus d'un an
et demi depuis octobre 2010 est comment
se passe ce premier mandat
tout d'abord bonjour merci merci de
m'accueillir ben écoutez le mandat se
passe bien enfin c'est on a fait
beaucoup d'événements depuis mon
élection on va rajouter aussi dans
l'équipe en place depuis une nouvelle
équipe en place de william hill 16 avait
occupé plusieurs postes de
vice-présidents donc c'est dans la
continuité dans la continuité donc voilà
l'université qui a eu des moments
difficiles alors on va pas revenir en
détail mais il ya eu le passage à
l'autonomie qui a été compliqué sur le
plan financier il ya même une fermeture
qui a été évoqué pendant quelques temps
aujourd'hui l'université retrouve de
bonnes places dans les classements
internationaux ça a été une des
priorités aussi de de ce début de mandat
pour vous oui alors je voudrais juste
revenir sur on rappelle assez souvent
les difficultés qu'ont pu connaître
universités mais elles sont je veux dire
ça fait déjà plusieurs années plus de 4
5 ans que que la situation budgétaire
d'université des scènes pour moi c'est
totalement l'histoire ancienne donc
effectivement je préfère retenir ce
qu'est ce qu'est l'université
aujourd'hui qu'il ait sa place donc calé
et qui symbolise ce qui est son sceau
d'excellence de la recherche c'est la
qualité de ses formations que
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines et est classée régulièrement
de manière constante d'ailleurs depuis
plusieurs années parmi dans le fameux
classement que le grand public connaît
le classement de shanghai
parmi eux entre la 500 et la 600e place
de l'université au au mondial également
dans d'autres classements peut-être
moins connu du grand public mais tout
aussi intéressants comme un classement
qui s'appelle th eu ta meilleure
éducation et il se trouve que
l'université est aussi classée parmi les
350 aujourd'hui avec ces résultats
remarquables ces universités pour
laquelle je suis très fier parce que si
vous ramenez au niveau national qui est
des plus parlants pour le public health
merci à versailles saint quentin en
yvelines se classe parmi la 25e ou la
huitième niveau national sur plus d'une
centaine en france et donc c'est c10
marca parce que ses universités comme
vous le savez qui est jeune donc il ya
moins de 30 ans qui est universités qui
pluridisciplinaire c'est qu'on n'est pas
sur une thématique sol et puis qui a
voilà c'est 1000 enseignants chercheurs
c'est moins de vingt mille étudiants
donc c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
symptomatique de ce qui est ce qui fait
les forces de cette université
université pluridisciplinaire
effectivement c'était pas le cas de
toutes les universités mais néanmoins
qu'est ce qui distingue
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qu'est-ce qui
fait son excellence aujourd'hui c'est la
recherche sur le climat c'est la santé
ce sont les sciences humaines le droit
vous avez cités ce qui si vous le citez
c'est effectivement ce qui peut ce qu'on
fait ressortir de l'université mais je
voudrais dire que les résultats qu'on a
dans les classements internationaux en
particulier c'est avant tout le fait
d'une mécanique nyrs un système
collectif souhaite un effort collectif
de l'ensemble de l'université pas le
fait de quelques uns de quelques
chercheurs
bien sûr ils sont là mais c'est aussi
parce que dans la vie d'université il ya
un moment des gens vont plus s'investir
à faire l'enseignement plus investir à
faire des parties administratives qui
permettent aux gens de développer la
recherche
donc effectivement les quatre et quatre
sujets que les cités sont sont
effectivement des thématiques des points
forts on en a plusieurs mais là notre
université s'est développée en s'axant
sur ce qu'on appelle des niches des
niches d'excellence et aujourd'hui c'est
le résultat de ces niches d'excellence
vous êtes on va parler un peu de vous
maintenant spécialiste de l'informatique
titulaire d'un doctorat dans ce domaine
depuis 1994 est ce que vous conjuguez
encore les deux activités où vous êtes
aujourd'hui pleinement président de
l'université vous n'avez plus
d'activités de recherche d'enseignement
alors j'ai toujours évidemment
un oeil sur la recherche ont vocation
mais la vérité c'est que le la fonction
de président fait que l'on doit être
exclusivement sur cette fonction est
donc effectivement j'ai déjà beaucoup
dans ma carrière je pu faire en quelque
sorte pour le dira si un peu le tour sur
sur ce qui est la formation la recherche
et aujourd'hui vance et tulle parenthèse
donc ça vous oblige à mettre une
parenthèse mais rien ne vous empêche t
on va dire par là c'est vraiment une
parenthèse où est ce que vous voyez
cette évolution enfin c'était prévu
comme une évolution vous avez occupé des
postes de vice présidents
aujourd'hui président au moment du
départ de voilà il ya un départ pour
raison médicale de l'ancien président
mais vous aviez prévu cette évolution
c'est ce que vous vouliez faire
professionnellement
après c'est une histoire d'opportunités
de qui fait que effectivement je suis
devenu président mais j'ai toujours j'ai
toujours eu cette envie de m'investir de
développer d'essayer voilà d'apporter
quelque chose à l'université de la
développer et voilà donc c'est disons
c'est la conjugaison de ces deux ces
deux mécanismes l'opportunité puisse oui
c'est cette envie de l'essayer
de développer d'apporter quelque chose
pour l'université qui participent et ce
n'est pas forcément quelque chose de ça
mais aussi créer une nouvelle dynamique
d'essayer de voilà vous avez évoqué tout
à l'heure les classements internationaux
et vous avez été vice président en
charge des relations internationales
notamment pour l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin ses relations
avec les autres pays
c'est un axe prioritaire pour
l'université de se positionner au niveau
mondial aussi alors les classements
internationaux c'est il ya eu beaucoup
de discussions ils prennent certains
critères qui peuvent être discutés après
une université c'est surtout par sa
recherche
pas uniquement mais essentiellement sa
recherche une recherche d'un monde
universitaire c'est forcément une
recherche quasiment ça dépend peut-être
quelques domaines qu'elle s'est passé un
peu moins le cas mais c'est une
recherche au niveau international donc
c'est les collaborations des chercheurs
avec d'autres chercheurs de différents
laboratoires dans le monde qui font
qu'ils font avancer la recherche et qui
finalement arriver à ce résultat dont
sont faits les universités françaises à
l'étranger justement j'ai bonne par
rapport aux autres universités
après le monde est vaste mais je pense
qu'elles sont bonnes on est on est
aujourd'hui on est enfin on le voit par
le nom de prix nobel ou medal fils que
la france peut avoir de manière
régulière
donc si une recherche et pas uniquement
science c'est également une science
humaine
s'il recherche de qualité donc ils
domaine sur lequel les chercheurs sont
reconnus d'ailleurs vous avez des
chercheurs français formés en france qui
vont ensuite exercé à l'étranger donc on
a système universitaire qui est je pense
qu'ils quitteraient bien vu mais qui
doit qui doit aussi savoir se remettre
en cause et c'est un peu ce qui se passe
dans le paysage universitaire
actuellement avec le regroupement des
universités pour en faire des entités
qu'elle puisse parler de l'université de
paris saclay justement parce que
l'avenir l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines fait
pleinement intégré dans ce projet
d'université paris saclay aujourd'hui
est-ce que lui vs qu à sa place au sein
de ce projet comme vous le souhaitez
alors lu vs qu a toujours eu sa place
après que on a toujours été là dès le
départ
donc elle va avoir pleinement sa place
et je pense que c'est important alors là
nombreux atouts pour valoriser mais
peut-être un mot sur l'humour c'est
pareil saclay c'est en fait c'est par
rapport à votre question précédente
c'est effectivement de pouvoir
construire une université parmi être
mieux dans les 20 premières mondiales et
pour paris saclay avec une on va dire
une redimensionnement un peu particulier
c'est un projet un peu particulier c'est
un projet qui va regrouper des
universités dont l'université paris-sud
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines et nuire ces d'evry avec des
grandes écoles comme centrale supélec la
nes externe donc c'est ce modèle un peu
particulier qui qui a peu inédit en
france qui va regrouper des grandes
écoles avec des universités qui qui
restructurent quelque part le paysage
l'enseignement supérieur la recherche et
donc c'est c'est un projet qui porte
il va porter notre université ce serait
voilà qu'ils participent et dont c'est
finalement c'est un projet extrêmement
ambitieux sur le voit aux états finale
et on aura toute notre place pour
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
vite j'ai pas d'inquiétude on a la
qualité on l'a vu je voulais dippach par
le travail qui est effectué par par nos
chercheurs et qui et puis nous
enseignants chercheurs nos personnels et
qui sont exprimées par les classements
internationaux qui ont de très beaux
campus on a des étudiants des très beaux
campus dont ici en particulier à saint
quentin en yvelines
donc tout ça je veux dire peut-être en
2025 moment où notre mrc fusionnera on
aura on aura peut-être plus universelle
versée à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'appellation tel qu'on l'entend mais
nos campus ici seront des campus de deux
universités paris saclay et y compris
ici dans le territoire des six lignes
dès 2025 2025 vous souhaitez encore être
président pour accompagner le changement
justement c'est trop tôt pour vous dire
je sais que j'ai le temps je juste le
temps présidentiel c'est vous voyez je
suis là depuis le 5 octobre 2017 quand
je me retourne j'ai l'impression que ça
fait beaucoup plus d'années parce que
effectivement c'est c'est un travail
extrêmement motivant mais avec beaucoup
beaucoup de pression beaucoup d' urgence
à traiter donc voilà chaque jour suffit
sa peine et l'essentiel c'est pour
l'instant pour moi c'est de mettre
l'université dans les bons rails
on l'a permet d'avoir de construire
pleinement et de s'associer pleinement
aux projets dans paris saclay et de
continuer à attirer justement les
étudiants dans cette université
aujourd'hui l'université et notamment
celles de versailles saint quentin est
une bonne porte d'entrée pour le monde
professionnel c'est ce qui a été
reproché aux universités par le passé un
cdd fois trop généraliste est pas
préparé au monde professionnel
aujourd'hui cette image est à oublier je
vous pose aussi cette question parce que
les étudiants sont en train de
s'inscrire pour les lycéens sur parcours
cible donc ils font leur choix justement
aujourd'hui vous pouvez leur conseiller
d'aller à l'université
et ça leur permettra de trouver un
travail d'être accompagnés vers ce monde
professionnel bien sûr mais elle se
l'est depuis plusieurs années mais
j'aurais peut-être mettre l'accent sur
ce qu'est l'université où les gens
peut-être non
on ne voit pas les atouts pour
l'université on accueille un public
hétérogène un public des bacs différents
et d'émotions différentes en échec
mention très bien des gens qui a
l'intention passage voilà et le but de
l'université c'est de pouvoir laisser le
choix orientés mieux les étudiants pour
trouvent leur voie qu'ils aient leur
chance et je trouve leur voix pour
exercer un métier mais linéaire cité
s'est pas uniquement
on n'est pas là pour former aux formes
évidemment pour que les gens puissent
rentrer dans le monde du travail mais ça
va un peu au-delà c'est à dire conforme
les étudiants enfin les jeunes adultes
non seulement à obtenir un travail
aujourd'hui mais à pouvoir se préparer
au travail
enfin monde du travail qu'il y aura
après demain après après demain c'est à
dire que on les fout on les forme pas
uniquement sur une compétence immédiate
mais aussi de pouvoir se former tout au
long de la vie voilà se remettre en
cause ce qui fait la spécificité de
l'université c'est que le corps
enseignant sa majorité c'est ce qu'on
appelle des enseignants chercheurs c'est
à dire qu'ils sont à moitié temps
enseignants et à moitié de temps
chercheurs donc ils travaillent dans les
laboratoires en pointe de la recherche
dans leur domaine et quelque part de
manière directe ou indirecte
ils transmettent ils sont les mieux
placés ils transmettent aux étudiants
baisse nous devons être les le futur
dans leur domaine
voilà les métiers du futur quelque part
elle les prépare aussi aux métiers du
futur à travers ça va terminer je vais
reprendre votre carrière avoue vous
parlais tout à l'heure de l'informatique
vous avez publié sur l'algorithme
distribuer la recherche opérationnelle
comment fait ce choix de carrière mais
ça peut paraître très pointue et voilà
c'est toujours on part d'une discipline
donc voilà je suis moi ce type nos
disciplines scientifiques
j'ai fait des mathématiques après voilà
à pitre je suis arrivé fox était un des
lots a donc sonné au niveau master on
commence à se spécialiser et après c'est
toujours la rencontre c'est la paix tant
de ce qu'on veut faire puis la rencontre
aussi mais justement des professeurs des
enseignants chercheurs qu'on rencontre à
l'université qui est qu'ils nous ouvrent
la voie qui nous guident la voix sur des
thématiques plus restreinte mais
finalement à travers ces termes là
ciseler si je vous parle de réfléchir
conceptuellement à ce que vont être les
réseaux de demain qui vous le comprenez
mieux tout le monde sait ce qu est
internet vous accessible et la recherche
opérationnelle baisser
c'est très intéressant c'est une matière
qui est à la frontière entre
l'informatique des matic les
mathématiques et l'économie et c'est
d'essayer d'optimiser voilà d'optimiser
sous contrainte donc voilà dix et de
chercher de peut-être dans un exemple
quel est le meilleur profit à faire dans
ces conditions-là d'envoyer ça peut être
des choses qui sont morts qui sont plus
par parenthèse et peut-être vous allez y
revenir plus tard après la présidence
entre parenthèses c'est sûr après je ne
sais pas dans le futur ce qu'il
adviendra merci beaucoup à l'envi
d'avoir discuté avec nous pendant ce
quart d'heure au cours de ce véhicule et
on se retrouve bientôt sur télé 78
[Musique]